bonjour antoine savignat jours merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous en direct
matin sur arte france alors on va
d'abord parlé de ce qui s'est passé à
l'assemblée nationale hier soir à la
surprise générale le pass sanitaires et
la sortie de l'état d'urgence en général
n'a pas été voté en première lecture est
ce que vous étiez sur place vous même
expliquez-nous et cette frontière de la
part du modem je n'étais pas sur glace
hier mais effectivement on a pu faire le
point sein du groupe je crois que le
groupe modem a refusé de voter avec la
majorité
le pass sanitaire que la majorité encore
une fois été à la fois divisée et pas
ses nombreuses dans l'hémicycle c'est
pas la première fois il faut se souvenir
de ce coup d'éclat d'olic et des grands
qui nous avait invités à quitter
l'hémicycle si nous n'étions pas
satisfaits lors de la lecture du
précédent texte sur la sortie d' état
d'urgence au cours puisque auourd'hui
départ nous avions modifié la date
initialement prévue par le gouvernement
de deux sorties d'état d'urgence
on voit bien que le gouvernement patton
que tout cela est géré de manière
approximative et qu'il a fallu une soie
lecture et un nouveau vote pour qu'ils
puissent pour qu'ils puissent parvenir à
ses fins mais je pense que c'est
l'expression de la lassitude des
français dans le cadre de la gestion qui
nous est proposé dans cette facilité
c'est assez rare que l'allié modem lâche
la majorité présidentielle écouter est
les raisons de cette de ce nom vote en
tout cas en première lecture par le
modem on vote sur quoi comme le
gouvernement a des pouvoirs exorbitants
ils mettent ensuite tout ce qu'il veut
dans le décret le passage au banc de
l'assemblée formel il y à peu
d'attention du gouvernement un autre
endroit voire un certain mépris c'est
vrai qu'on en entend souvent un ses
objections le fait que les députés ne
sont pas suffisamment entendue il a
fallu que l'exécutif lâche du lest hier
soir pour voter cette cette sortie de
l'état d'urgence oui mais se trouve le
décalage total entre l'exécutif et ce
que peuvent ressentir l'ensemble des
français d'ensemble nos compatriotes
face à la gestion de cette crise
sanitaire le gouvernement est déconnecté
et la question de ce pass sanitaire
demeure puisqu'on va nécessairement
créer des inégalités on n'a pas
aujourd'hui puis vacciner
l'intégralité de la population n'aura
pas vaccinés dans les mois à venir
l'intégralité de la population et on
peut effectivement se questionner sur
l'opportunité de cette mesure de fichage
attentatoires aux libertés des uns et
des autres alors même que le
gouvernement dispose déjà de pouvoir
exorbitant dans le cadre de ces textes
sur la gestion des crises sanitaires
puisqu'il peut légiférer par ordonnances
à sa guise ce que le modem a bien obtenu
l'ouverture des discothèques au 1er
juillet c'est ce cas c'est ce qu'ont
laissé entendre certains journalistes
mais le gouvernement n'a pas confirmé ce
matin je suis comme vous le gouvernement
n'a pas le confirmer mais beaucoup de
choses ne sont pas confirmées encore et
ne sont pas certaines dans le cadre de
la gestion de la sortie de la crise
sanitaire puisque le gouvernement a
toujours été extrêmement prudent dans
ses propos et précise bien que toutes
les mesures annoncées le sont sous
réserve de l'évolution de la situation
sanitaire donc j'aimerais qu'ils ne
s'engagent en ce sens il faut pas
oublier qu'aujourd'hui ça fait plus d'un
an que les discothèques sont fermées et
que ce secteur est également en péril et
en grand péril
s'il ne pouvait pas reprendre eux aussi
normalement une activité dans les
semaines à venir
alors vous dites reprendre eux aussi
cette question des discothèques a fait
l'objet d'une remarque du député
philippe gosselin hier dans l'hémicycle
il a pointé les incohérences dans les
calendriers de réouverture de certains
établissements dans le cadre de cette
sortie de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
je vous laisse regarder la séquence y en
en parle après vous refuser d'intégrer
le cas échéant il n'est pas demandé dès
ce soir la rouverture par christophe
blanche et éventuellement
discothèque mais c'est de permettre au
cas où au 1er juillet ça serait possible
de le faire
eh bien non oui bah savez vous par
ailleurs je sais que ça fera sourire
mais que les clubs libertins eux vont
pouvoir ré ouvrir et il est bien connu
que dans ces clubs en pratique tous les
gestes barrière c'est même d'ailleurs
pour ça c'est même d'ailleurs pour ça
qu'on y va alors voilà est-ce qu'elle
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ces
incohérences je rappelle que les clubs
libertins sont gérés comme les salles de
sport selon selon le code du tourisme
alors voilà pourquoi ça rouvre avant
mais c'est vrai que c'est pas très
cohérent vous pourrez effectivement
henry ou en sourire mais ça prouve toute
l'incohérence dans la gestion de la
sortie de cette crise il est évident que
les clubs libertins ouvrant les dix
spots elles doivent également pouvoir
pouvoir ouvrir avec des conditions
peut-être dans un premier temps de jauge
comme ce sera le cas pour les
restaurants avec le respect des gestes
barrières mais vous savez je pense aussi
qu'il faut arrêter on est français pour
des imbéciles ils ont bien compris la
gravité de cette crise sanitaire les
enjeux pour les uns et les autres et je
ne pense pas qu'il y ait des gens
souhaitant s'exposer de manière
démesurée les gens veulent juste vivre
revivre et avoir enfin une vie sociale
normale et qu'il reprenne son cours
c'est juste ça donc il faut aussi leur
faire leur faire confiance et il faut
leur permettre de retourner à une vie
normale
on en vient à cette polémique si vous le
voulez bien qu'il déstabilise aussi la
majorité présidentielle c'est cette
candidate voilée sur une affiche de
campagne pour les départementales le
délégué général dans marche a assuré
hier qu'elle ne serait pas soutenue par
le parti
ce qui fait polémique c'est qu'il a
relayé un tweet de jordan bardella du
rassemblement national regardez c'est
cela la lutte contre le séparatisme
marlène schiappa les valeurs portées par
arm ne sont pas compatibles avec le port
ostentatoire de signes religieux sur un
document de campagne électorale soit ces
candidats changent leur photo soit lrm
leur retirera leur soutien à ce qui est
tombé dans un piège stanislas guérini
selon vous
je ne sais pas s'il est tombé dans un
piège mais c'est la preuve qu'il n'ya
pas de colonne vertébrale à la
république en marche stanislas béré n'y
parle de valeur portée on voit bien que
le sujet divise la majorité en son sein
la journée d'hier a été un long débat au
sein même de la majorité sur ce thème et
il est pour le moins effectivement
contradictoire de vouloir d'un côté nous
parler de séparatisme de l'autre laissé
faire ce genre d'affiché de voir que
finalement au sein même de la majorité
nombre sont pour d'autres son compte
ce qui prouve bien qu'ils aillent et il
leur manque cette colonne vertébrale il
leur manque ses valeurs comme stanislas
guérini encore une fois parle de valeur
je ne sais pas ce qu'elle son regard du
débat suscité par à la fois cette
affiche et l'éventualité de la perte de
l'investiture de la république en marche
pour les personnes figurant sur cette
affiche c'est c'est l'illustration
encore une fois du manque de repères de
la majorité sur nombre de grands thèmes
sociétaux
ce n'est pas illégal d'apparaître voilée
sur une affiche néanmoins est-ce que
c'est souhaitable selon vous je pense
que ce n'est pas souhaitable après on
est dans le cadre d'une élection les
électeurs vont avoir à faire des choix
et bah finalement on s'aperçoit que ces
candidats nous n'avance pas masqué il
faudra que les électeurs en tirent les
conséquences je pense que c'est pas
souhaitable parce que ça n'est pas le
débat républicain que d'afficher de
manière ostentatoire son appartenance
religieuse après encore une fois libre
eux de le faire si s'il ne soit que le
faire je ne je ne serai pas moi même si
on me posait la question à mener est
rationnée ce type de comportement alors
on en vient à cette manifestation de
soutien hier à toulouse est la deuxième
tribune des militaires qui embarrasse
aussi le gouvernement un officiel
gendarmerie est sorti de sa réserve hier
dans les média écouté il m'a semblé que
le devoir de vérité était plus important
que le devoir de réserve
ce que nous traversons depuis des années
des mois maintenant me paraît trop grave
au regard des violences au regard de
l'insécurité des injustices que le
peuple français a à connaître
il m'a semblé nécessaire
de faire connaître cette réalité le
peuple de france a le droit que l'on
dise les choses que l'on cesse d'être
dans ce déni et a le droit au changement
le gouvernement qui on l'a vu a tout
fait pour discréditer ces deux tribunes
sans finalement parler du fond qu'en
pensez vous est ce que finalement les
les propos je parle du fond est-ce que
le constat avait le mérite d'être
publiées selon vous le constat je pense
qu'on est nombreux à le faire depuis
longtemps et le fond de cette tribune
étaient là c'est effectivement un triste
constat que l'on peut faire aujourd'hui
je vous cache pas que la forme me gêne
un peu quand vous citiez cet officier de
gendarmerie qui dit il m'a semblé que le
devoir de réserve mais existent dans
l'intérêt public et dans l'intérêt dans
l'ambulance le centre de l'as de la
société et j'ai du mal à concevoir qu'un
homme seul puisse à lui parce qu'il en
est convaincu décidé de supprimer ce de
faire sauter ce verrou et ce devoir de
réserve alors même que le fonds est
partagée que tous ces militaires et des
élus qu'il aurait pu qu'il aurait pu
faire passer aussi le message à leurs
élus pour qu'ils soient répercutées dans
dans la société
sur le fond on peut avoir des
inquiétudes mais on les a tous quand on
entend le président de la république
dire qu'il veut des construire notre
histoire
je peux concevoir que des militaires qui
se battent au quotidien pour protéger
notre pays qui se sont battus pour
protéger notre pays soit totalement d
amuser en entendant ce type de propos le
général de cointrin d'ailleurs a écrit
une lettre hier à ses troupes le chef de
l'état major des armées qui a tenté de
calmer le jeu il parle justement de ce
devoir de réserve écouter l'obligation
de réserve qui s'impose à tout militaire
a été largement transgresser notre
obligation de réserve et souvent mal
comprise si elle limite effectivement la
liberté d'expression elle préserve
absolument la liberté d'opinion
alors on a très peu de temps pour réagir
et là
afin d'apaiser les choses le général le
cointre je crois qu'on a tout intérêt à
apaiser les choses aujourd'hui et qu'on
a plus intérêt à ce que ce type de
messages se multiplient se multiplient
quotidiennement il est dans la mission
qui est la sienne d'un appel au calme
d'un appel à la sérénité comme il le dit
très justement c'est ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure ses militaires
d'une liberté d'opinion ils peuvent
faire part qu'ils veulent de leur
opinion mais pas de cette manière pad
pas dans la presse
ça paraît antinomique avec ce qu'il
dénonce
merci beaucoup antoine savignat d'avoir
répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur arte france